my coughs tastes like chocolate
[Music]
apparently we're here to snort chocolate
it's gonna be interesting to see how it
goes supposed to make me really focused
and kind of give me energy throughout
the day I'm a huge chocolate lover I've
eaten it in almost every form hot
chocolate dark chocolate I've had
chocolate everywhere you can think of
here we go basically if I mix this with
milk I think I could make chocolate milk
it looks a little clumpy so I'm gonna
put it closer to me because I have to
get my nose down on it
can I have a straw Oh watery like it
kind of tastes like Ghirardelli
chocolate and I said taste not smell it
like goes down your throat and you like
a taste
I mean it's chocolate obviously so it
tastes good it's not like the most
painful thing but it's really
uncomfortable yeah initially I'm not
feeling much should I do another one my
whole head feels like it's just in like
a chocolate bubble but I also still
think that it might be Ovaltine I did
get like a little burst of energy on the
car ride over here kind of made me
anxious and then I like had to put on
some calming music I don't feel jittery
yet I'm waiting to see if it happens
that my nose still smells like chocolate
all of it I can taste it said it's
telling like a little bit of flowers
here or like the morning dew I was just
like chocolate chocolate chocolate
chocolate everything so like chocolate I
was hyper there for 30 minutes I think
not much has changed with my work or my
energy at this point I think there's
specific things you should use it for
not an 8-hour workday though I would I
was up and then I was down I mean I
could see how maybe it would be good for
festival or something like if you're
like it's kind of like taking a 5-hour
energy shot
would I do it again I would say that I'm
still in love with the Coco just not the
Coco Loco I might do it again but I'm
not gonna like go buy some Coco Loco or
like use that as an energy replacement
of any sorts I'm for sure going back to
caffeine
[Music]